let me tell you a quick story involving
a police shooting we've talked about
many many cases where police officers
were able to keep their jobs after
killing someone that was unarmed or
killing someone after responding to the
wrong house or killing someone and then
lying about it I have a story from West
Virginia where a police officer named
Stephen Mader was fired because he
didn't shoot someone he was fired for
not shooting someone Stephen Mader was
called to uh the home of 23 year old
black man Ronald Williams Jr by Jr's
girlfriend saying he has a gun
and he's thinking of killing himself
he's threatening to kill himself officer
Stephen Mader showed up and he indeed
found himself confronting an armed man
but he used his training as a police
officer to say okay hold on let me let
me assess the situation this is a man
who does have a firearm but he doesn't
seem at all like he's about to use it he
sort of pointing it down and one thing
that Williams jr. did that also made
officer Mader hesitate to shoot him is
he said just shoot me and very quickly
officer Mader identified mr. Williams
jr. as someone who wanted to be killed
by police this is called suicide by cop
and he said this is not someone that
should be shot we need a mental health
intervention here so he spoke to the
individual he said hey I'm not going to
shoot you and he successfully
de-escalated such the situation
reportedly using what he described as
his calm voice unfortunately two other
police officers showed up and ended up
shooting Williams dead as the story goes
Williams did get agitated by the arrival
of those two other police officers and
did start waving his gun around the gun
later turned out to be uh unloaded there
were no rounds in this weapon at all no
way that police could have known that
and he was ultimately shot by the two
cops that showed up Stephen Mader
initially thought that he would just
have his one week off which happens
typically after officers are involved in
a shooting it is sort of a period to
cool off if they need uh some counseling
or whatever else may be needed in terms
of that
emotional side they're able to get it
but when he came back to work or thought
he was coming back to work he was told
no actually we are not going to be
bringing you back on there is an
investigation going on he was ultimately
let go because he put the lives of his
other officers in danger by not shooting
this man this is absolutely disturbing
now you might hear it and say well but
David the other two cops showed up and
then the guy did wave the gun around and
then he got shot yeah we could have that
conversation but the big picture here is
we have a police officer who was
actually well equipped to de-escalate a
situation who was actually well equipped
not to just fire not to just start
discharging his gun and had successfully
done so until these two other officers
showed up now are the other two officers
to blame for escalating the situation we
know that mr. Williams was absolutely
emotionally unstable we know all of
those things but why are we punishing
the police officer who opted to
de-escalate and to actually prevent or
he could have prevented a police
shooting merely because later on the
suspect rijeka lated it is absolutely
deplorable and if we want to do anything
to push back against this shoot first
figure it out later mentality that
exists with some police officers not all
but with some police officers the first
thing we need to be doing is not
punishing an officer who opted to
successfully de-escalate rather than
discharging his firearm absolutely
disgusting